[Music]
yeah that was really good everyone loved
it
[Laughter]
james blunt is joining in
with
uh neil young and all these guys joanie
mitchell joe rogan in a different way oh
my god i like i like this one he has
threatened to release new music on
spotify
wow that's funny oh that's great is it a
troll no yep i will i assume stopper
want to make more music
yeah that's [ __ ] hansen should come back
too and we're like if joe rogan doesn't
come out right now we're going to come
out with a new single yeah that's dope
what's another music artist that you
guys don't like don't like
i don't really like not like james blunt
who's the i used to love him but then
the oh
those guys what the biscuit is that's a
biscuit that's not biscuit doesn't suck
though
yeah
disturbed yeah yeah p.o.d
it definitely sucks yeah yeah
that's like yeah i just realized i
actually don't like james blunt really
yeah you got beef with him i mean it's
just like whack [ __ ] i don't know
he
it's not like a [ __ ] connoisseur's
point of view it's like it's my reaction
is very that's just kind of whack oh
dear very uneducated not like b-boy
right there yeah it's that it's just
like
yeah i don't know [ __ ] lyrics are
just so [ __ ] mainstream sounding to
me it's probably not for you you got
your face in a crowded place and i don't
know what to do yeah he's like i don't
like him knows all the lyrics baby right
there
hey that sounds kind of good you know
sometimes music is made for the middle
class and the masses and we just got to
be okay with that because people want to
buy things at the mall you know that
[ __ ] sounds like baby shark the prequel
to me
i like pissed off ryan wow
yeah british
wait uh because you are actually a music
a musician that like we respect and
stuff who else do you not like yeah yeah
let's go who else i don't like i'm not
better than any of these people by the
way that's okay but as far as you're as
a consumer i'm just like yeah i just
want to know who you hate is there
anyone like on the radio that you're
like i don't see
why people like this he's like everyone
yeah or like gwen stefani's i don't know
because that's that's hard because it's
it's easy for me to find reasons why
like i can understand why a lot of [ __ ]
is liked because if it's different but
if it's so
like cookie cutter like then that's when
i'm like
that's when i actually think
no wonder people like it because if you
think about the world right
in a bell curve the mass is like
standard things just like they dress
bland they like things that are cookie
cutter so it's like crocodile dundee hat
yeah i like things that are either
extremely broke and different or
extremely rich and extravagant i don't
like the middle yeah but i think that's
a creative person's like outlook because
like style and cultures are are usually
created by the two outliers not by the
consumer masses yeah yeah so that's why
but but when you do have something
standard and pop and whatever
um the middle ground people love it yeah
i think it's not like uh i like the art
of having to reinvent pop all the time
because that's probably the [ __ ]
hardest thing to do but like bonnie
mckee who's like a really great producer
she uh like wrote teenage dream for katy
perry and she always says that like pop
is uh
it's basically saying the same thing
uh in a way that wasn't said before like
but it's you're saying it's like an
action movie that's just hard yeah cause
she's like if you look at the lyrics of
teenage dream it's basically just saying
how attracted you are to somebody in
another way but it's not a different new
statement what about this what about the
song that goes you had a bad day you run
that song
yeah good thing good now i feel like
that guy that's actually i mean
that guy and james blunt they blew up
that's true
it's about the same [ __ ] they were ford
versus ferrari to you
they were the innovators
of radio music at the time so wait so
neil young so so i remember this on uh
twitter where neil young was like i'm
gonna i'm gonna take all my music off a
spotify cause i don't want to be on the
same platform as that joel rogan who
says they can have rogan or young not
both
with an estimated 11 million listeners
per month jre which is host of
exclusively on spotify is the world's
largest podcast has tremendous influence
and they have a responsibility to
mitigate the spread of misinformation on
their platform but the company presently
has no misinformation policy
that's hilarious because
first off if he's gonna accuse him of
misinformation
shouldn't he um list out what the
misinformation is yeah cause a lot of
people are actually writing off joe
rogan right now and just saying like oh
he's spreading lies he's um you know
kovit lies he's giving people that are
anti-vaxxers and covet like a platform
and all this stuff and i'm like
i've listened to all of those yeah and
i don't know when the media wouldn't let
bernie talk or andrew yang talk like
during the democrat primaries yeah and
the only place that they could go was
joe rogan and then both of them were on
joe rogan talking about how the media
only lets you talk in sound bites and
you basically like sit there you you
wait to talk and you have three minutes
and then everybody gets their clips
digested by whatever however they
present that or chop you up chop you up
so so then the way that they liked that
joe rogan had a place where they could
talk at length about real issues instead
of all those [ __ ] in depth i
remember when back then i remember a lot
of people on the left were like this is
this is so cool that joe rogan has a
place where they can actually go and
talk yeah and joe rogan just does that
for everybody no matter what you think
which i think you know threatens a lot
of these guys who want to control every
[ __ ] word of the narrative yeah i
don't know what like specific lines of
misinformation
he actually has or what they're accusing
him of but what is crazy it's that it's
escalated so big that even the white
house is telling spotify there's more
that you can do i'm like holy [ __ ] it's
that big of a deal but even his video
that he released where he says look i
have a certain i've had
um a large majority of people talk about
coven maybe on one side and he goes
maybe i do need to have the opposing
side a little bit more or have a better
discussion with other minds that are on
opposite ends of their spectrum of what
they think about kovid and he's like i
could do a better job of doing that and
when would you ever hear a medium he's a
better man than me
you would never hear anybody like saying
like yeah first of all [ __ ] you
especially especially if you're joe
rogan and you know you're like i'm just
trying to have a conversation and that's
what the whole
like that's how his podcast blew up is
just having conversations with people
that people don't really have but if you
go against the narrative of mainstream
media you are such a threat and it shows
right now like okay so cnn
they went after him right saying that
he's doing horse tranquilizers and this
and that and they even dude it's so
[ __ ] crazy they even like made his
uh uh image like like green or lean and
gray and ugly yeah they made him look
sicker and then
isn't it the president of cnn like going
through some like sexual assault thing
with cuomo too yeah well no he um he was
commiserating with a co-worker
apparently but still
um people think there's more to that
story but he just resigned
oh [ __ ] well
you know
[ __ ] on joe rogan yeah it's been pretty
[ __ ] nuts man because all those guys
are contested
that's he kind of looks hard though he
kind of looks good right there
they made the tree look better too
all the alphabet medias right nbc abc
all those guys right uh they're all
sponsored by pfizer moderna whatever
they're also
in their like um
uh what do you call it in their
executive board right there are former
members of the military and all this
stuff right and so
the thing is like when they talk about
news as if oh we are a rep reputable
source you got to come to us whatever
whatever they're also not exposing like
who their spot like like hey we have
connections and ties to these things so
you might have an incentive to make your
sponsors look good or your friends look
good if they're in the military if
they're retired cia agents all this
stuff right if they're a part of your
staff and this is not like a [ __ ]
interest is it not a conflict of
interest but are conflicts of interest
the conspiracy theory now apparently
they are no it's and it shouldn't be a
conspiracy because it's an actual fact
that they have cia they have military
retired peoples they have all them in
their board of executives in all the
agencies right they have them in these
media outlets so when these guys are
going out there and saying like wait
joel rogan spreading missing information
you need to come to us because we're a
real news source and we don't do that
[ __ ] and it's like actually you are you
are doing exactly that it's [ __ ] nuts
especially with cnn that's what we're
talking about right now let's just watch
let's just watch it together
cbs health watch sponsored by
pfizer anderson cooper 360.
pfizer
abc news night live
brought to you by the
cnn
difference
brought to you by pfizer this goes on
for a long time
love it i would love it too and we
[ __ ] say everything good about pfizer
yeah me too but they gotta pay me yeah
give me eight million dollars and so
behind the scenes right people will be
like well they're just sponsored by them
but they're a news source we'll get it
guess what like when we get sponsored by
different
you know companies inside it's like
basically written that you don't [ __ ]
talk [ __ ] about the company we're super
busy sponsoring you yeah
you're not gonna be sponsored by [ __ ]
coca-cola and then do a video about how
coca-cola is [ __ ] you know creating
obesity and [ __ ] cause i'll pull the
plug on your ass exactly you said that
by the way you so you go ahead and cut
that you're like bart does a joke about
how coke gets you fat guess what they
spit that right back at you and like do
it again you know what like that's just
how it is [ __ ] like but people
uh it's remember when uh mythbusters
didn't uh
the asian guy from mythbuster did a
little special showing that mcdonald's
uh chicken nuggets were real chicken did
you believe that
no i never saw that what was that they
just they basically paid him to do a
mythbusters thing showing that the
mcdonald's food was actually really good
chicken it's not the pink pasty
no like it was like a weird it was a
brand integration and i was like that is
the biggest buyout i've ever seen in my
life like did they actually do that one
didn't didn't they actually do a moment
where they're like all right now we're
using real chicken in their chicken
nuggets they're like okay now i think
they say that now 100 real chicken this
is now like made with all white meat or
something like that yeah so aka wasn't
chicken before that's why
if like if you think about that if you
had to go as far as to get myth busters
to show your food then you knew there
was something [ __ ] up about it but it
tastes so good though
that's what they were fighting against
super size me that's what was happening
did you guys ever give a [ __ ] if it was
chicken or dude no that's the thing like
that's what they need to do is be like
hey you guys [ __ ] like it they needed
me in the focus group i would have told
them there's a [ __ ] matter yeah yeah
i'm gonna go there it doesn't matter why
are you trying to be so healthy shut up
yeah
so
like that's it and everybody would sell
you because super size meme [ __ ] made
me go get mcdonald's right afterwards it
made me hungrier
i thought the dude eat i think two meals
back to back yeah and he's like
take it anymore so he throws up out of
the car i'm like what a [ __ ] [ __ ] i
was like oh you're the one that did it
you're the one that signed up for this
did they like eventually uncover that he
was like on all these drugs oh i don't
know some [ __ ] i think he had some
issues what a reason to get mcdonald's
for lunch yeah [ __ ] yeah we used to eat
mcdonald's for like breakfast and lunch
and sometimes dinner just don't eat
mcdonald's three times a week we sound
like responsible
don't eat anything three times a day
i will say that one time that they did
that that thing where they put
mcdonald's like fries and burgers in
like a uh something for a long time oh
yeah and then it looks the same after
like a year it does it does but i'm like
oh [ __ ] there's gotta be something
[ __ ] up with the food but it still
tastes hella good no it'll be all right
it helps you become immortal like you
kind of know what you're getting into
when you order mcdonald's you're just
[ __ ] out it's fine the fact that i'm
still alive and i'm 36 years old is a
[ __ ] stunner yeah
and you're stunning dude considering the
[ __ ] i put in my body over the years are
you [ __ ] kidding me dude
it's a preservative human beings are
resilient mcdonald's fries do suck
though when they're not hot oh oh
no no no no no mcdonald's fries knocked
out right now dog fries stuck now
they used to be good they used to use
animal fat all kinds of these
they changed them yeah and now i gotta
go to burger king to have a decent fry
they used animal fabrics that's what
made it good they used lard on the
because i remember uh
as a seventh day i would since we
couldn't eat well we weren't supposed to
eat mcdonald's because they cooked it in
pork oil yeah and you can't have pork so
they would tell us oh you can't actually
have that that's the reason why i
couldn't have uh hostess products
because i use pork oil to make twinkies
and ding dong
pork in a twinkie
i don't know what they're still is do
the research
because a lot of the point i don't want
to do research on something but muslims
i know they like twinkies
it's like a muslim national food
you